no one cares what you're doing nobody
cares about you every single person is
completely wrapped up in debt on lives
when you walk into a room no one's
looking at you when you drop a glass of
Coke down the front of your top no one
cares no one remembers there is nothing
more liberating than realizing how
indifferent the rest of the world is to
what you're doing you are the center of
your own universe and you basically
don't even exist in anybody else's that
should be the best antidote to social
anxiety that I can think of
Hello everybody welcome back to the show
it is an 800 000 subscriber q a episode
and has around about 700 000 of you will
be familiar with this means that I ask
for questions from Twitter and locals
and YouTube community and Instagram and
there were way more than I'm gonna have
time to get through today but we've
bundled them together and I'm going to
try and get through as many as I can
before we get into the episode I do want
to give an announcement that I am going
on tour I'm going to be doing live shows
later this year and you get to choose
which cities I go to if you go to Chris
Williamson dot live you can enter the
city that you live in and we're just
going to use that information to help
root the different locations that I'll
go to to do the live event I absolutely
can't wait to put everybody into a room
together uh my imposter syndrome around
why am I stood on stage in front of
hundreds of people is going to take a
little bit of work to drop off before
this happens but I really really really
excited to do it and
you guys get to choose where I go so go
to Chris Williamson dot live put your
city in and also you'll find out first
when show dates and locations and
tickets are all announced as well let's
get into it
Jackson Pekin my dead end Factory job
pays 120 Grand but it is depressing how
would you make the leap to quit
think about how good you are at doing a
job that you hate
and now think about how good you would
be if you were doing a job that you love
like really what you're doing is you're
exchanging sanity for time and it's
that's the cost right like sometimes
sanity involves lots of time sometimes
it involves lots of cognitive effort
sometimes it involves you being
depressed or unhappy and you could
basically see exchanging money for
sanity as well if I get a more enjoyable
job which pays me less money it Nets out
at the same because think about all of
the coping mechanisms that you're
probably going through in a desperate
attempt to put up with this job you
might be training less you might be
going less outgoing you might be
spending more time on your phone you
might be turning to other drugs like
weed or nicotine
all of those will fall away
if you were to switch jobs and you would
probably also be much better at what you
do
all the thingies nine what did you think
about the response to your diary of a
CEO Instagram reel yes very interesting
the Fiat 500 Instagram club uh took
offense at some of the things that I
said on that podcast reel
um
every single person that's ever listened
to Modern wisdom knows exactly my
position when it comes to the dating
market like I am in the eyes of the
manosphere so blue pilled I'm a cook and
in the eyes of Guardian readers so
bigoted that I'm a misogynist like if I
split the difference between those two
so be it like I I really loved that
episode I I thought that the Reel was
spicely edited together but it did what
we need to like Steven's team has a like
a very quick cut style the way that they
put their their shorts together and
yeah the the comment section spoke for
itself it's a bunch of you know a lot of
them are women who maybe haven't been
exposed to this stuff before but I can't
go any gentler than that if you listen
to what I'm saying especially on the
podcast it's like
so delicate we can't roll back women's
education and employment we can't do
this like this is how difficult it is
for girls like blah blah blah blah blah
if I caveat it anymore I would basically
be
I would be lying I would be I would be
um dampening down the insights so much
that no one actually got to any truth
anymore the other thing I was talking to
David Buss about this yesterday
I feel so bulletproof in the science
around this there's no other topic on
the planet that I know as well as
intersexual Dynamics mating and
attraction
and because of that it means that if I
do get pushback like that typically if
you were unless well-grounded footing
you'd be like oh no what if I'm not
actually my position might not be too
certain here every single stat that I
cited I'm happy to give references for
every single position that I had there I
went yeah I I feel like that was what I
meant to say I think it's accurately
grounded in science and I think that it
is fair and put forward in a empathetic
and well-meaning way and if the Fiat 500
Instagram Club doesn't like that then
I don't care
Sarah Grace W after all of your
conversations about females do you think
you understand us more or less smiley
face that's a very good question
um
I'd like to think more I do think more
um there is a Chasm when you start
learning about evolutionary psychology
where you
stop seeing people as people and start
seeing them as just a collection of
traits and signals that they're doing
um but I'm out of that on the other side
now
um
everyone's complex right absolutely
everybody is
but
I do think that a good grounded
understanding of human nature through
evolutionary psychology
helps to make people a little bit less
murky
lj22 you recently spoke with Alex homozy
about the starving rat experiment where
the animal has a reward to run toward
the smell of cheese and something they
fear to run away from the smell of a cat
at this stage in life what would you say
is a reward you're running toward an a
fear you were running from and if you
had a figurative spring attached to your
figurative tail do you think it would be
the reward or the fear making you pull
more forcefully
um it's definitely more reward than it
is fear now it was fair for a very very
long time it's maybe 50 50. I don't know
um I try and ER on the side of finding
things that are good of running towards
paying forward the benefits and insights
and opportunities that I've had to learn
that have really helped me to become a
better version of myself
it feels like
modern wisdom is the podcast that I wish
that I'd had 10 years ago because it
would have taught me a lot of the things
about the world that I really needed to
hear and this is why I love doing it
because if I didn't run this show I
would listen to this show like this is
the podcast that I want to listen to I
just happen to be an active participant
in making it happen
um in terms of running away from stuff
there's still some senses of
insufficiency you know like there is
some negative inner voices that I get if
I fall short of my own expectations and
they're pretty cutting and pretty brutal
at times
it's a lot quieter than it used to be
but it's still very much there and like
way more than would be optimal
um
but
it is getting better so I'd say maybe 50
50 at the moment in terms of my amount
of force and it would be just trying to
make the best of all of the
opportunities that I've got at the
moment I really think that the
conversations we're having here are
super super important I appreciate all
of you guys for being incredibly
sensible and reasonable and having
amazing interesting curious
conversations in the comments or there's
this new question sticker that you can
do on on Spotify which you may not have
seen which is really cool and no one
else sees that except for me and the
guys behind the scenes so
um yeah it's awesome I really like what
we're talking about and I think it's
important so that's driving me to do
more
rummy congratulations Chris what is your
attachment style how was your
relationship with your parents when you
were growing up I love your podcast
female listener here from Argentina
thank you Rami from South America
I think I'm mostly anxious attachment uh
relationship with parents was great mum
and Dad's looked after me a lot they
were quite Stern they were you know I
was disciplined and I knew sort of where
the lines were
um I've kind of get the impression that
attachment style is very very heavily
heritable rather than environmentally
inculcated
I would love to see some of these
studies about crying it out and babies
being left on their own replicated and
whether or not they do I think that they
would be I think that you're going to
see them struggle so I don't think that
my relationship with my parents growing
up would massively impact my attachment
style however I do have anxious
attachment to a degree I've worked on
that too and that has been helped by
having a greater sense of confidence in
myself and being
more grounded in the things that I'm
doing and not playing a role so much uh
yeah
well man lifestyle appreciate all of
your insights as well as your guests of
the show it is a massive inspiration to
be better every day congratulations on
800 000 brother cheers to community
thank you very much awesome always
brings a smile to my face when a man
doing good work is being rewarded for it
keep up the good work so Patrick Connors
thank you these are not questions uh
it's my fault how would you say your
writing style has changed or developed
through the time you've been doing this
podcast are you trying to actively shape
it or do you just want to get better at
getting your points across without any
stylistic direction in mind
hmm writing style has changed because of
the
newsletter and that has been a massive
change because every single week I need
to get about a thousand words down
um I've become shorter with my writing
style sentences are shorter I'm trying
to shape it to be as simple as possible
I like using cool language but it
doesn't convey as easily over written
words as it does when you're hearing it
I think you can afford to be a little
bit more flamboyant with your language
when you're speaking but when you're
writing you actually want to optimize
just for Simplicity and accessibility
unless you need to be a little bit more
like verbose or whatever so yeah that
would be the changes
Greaves underscore Josh can you tell us
more about the project you and James
Smith are working on
uh
soon yes very soon me and James are
going to be launching something this
year super super excited
nearly but not quite yet
um yeah
so well deserved a little Billy so well
deserved I would not mentally be the
same man I am now without modern wisdom
what guest from the last year has
challenged you the most intellectually
when talking to them I know there are
people I talk to that require me to use
a lot of brain power keeping up While
others are much less taxing to talk to
that's Stephen Shore episode about
population collapse was just like a Out
of Body Experience because it's just
such a frame shift around how I thought
the entire world was working and and
what I was
or what I thought about the future of
humanity
um it wasn't it wasn't difficult to
speak to him but every sentence that he
said was causing 10 different questions
to arise in my mind so I would say maybe
him
will you have Iman Ghazi on your podcast
okay so I actually kept a secret from
you guys up to now which is we trained a
language learning model on 250 podcast
episodes that I spoke on and every
single blog post that I ever wrote
so we have a crispot that supposedly is
able to answer questions in as
effectively of a way as I would um so
I'm going to ask some of the questions
from today
to the crispart and we will compare what
it says with what I would have said uh
and maybe we'll even let it make some
decisions so Hamza asked will you have
Iman Ghazi on your podcast so I'll ask
chrisbot will you have Iman godzi on
your podcast Iman godzi is someone I've
been wanting to have on the podcast for
a while now I'm always looking for
interesting people to interview and
imangazi definitely fits the bill I'm
hoping to have him on the podcast soon
decision is made I will reach out to
Iman I have a mutual friend
crispot is already influencing the
progress of this show
I've just started following your content
recently and I've just seen how you used
to record podcasts in a not so fancy way
that is a very complementary way of
saying that it was [__] uh just because
the show we all start somewhere my
question would be what had kept you
going
I just loved the conversations I've
always spoken to people that I'm
interested in talking to on the podcast
for most of the almost every single
person that's come on the podcast is
because I can't wait to learn from them
that is the most powerful motivating
fuel that I can think of like all that
you're going to do is continue to
satisfy your curiosity over and over and
over and over again
there was no just because it wasn't
fancy because I I wasn't getting as many
plays because no one was no one cared
about the podcast or me or anyone that I
was speaking to
I wanted to keep going because it was
what I wanted to do I wasn't doing this
for anybody else and you know it goes
back to that question about the guy that
earns a ton of money but works in a
factory that he hates
your
using uh external motivator to motivate
yourself because intrinsically you're
not enjoying what you're doing I was
enjoying what I was doing so it didn't
matter about the fact that I started
somewhere and that somewhere was a
little bit crap
Tim kilro is finding a quality woman
harder for this generation than it was
for my father let's ask Chris Bott
whether he thinks that it's more
difficult to find a quality woman in
this generation he might throw me under
the bus here
I think it's hard to make a
generalization about this as everyone's
experience is difficult however I do
think that technology has changed the
way we interact with each other and that
can make it harder to find meaningful
connections it's important to take the
time to get to know someone and build a
strong Foundation before making any
decisions
hmm
not far off uh technology changes the
way we've interact and that makes it
harder to make meaningful connections
yes next thing very difficult
um I think it's harder for both sides
also it's important to take time to get
to know someone and build a strong
Foundation before ask making any
decisions what do I think about that
yeah yeah I think I think all of those
Chris Bud's not done a bad job there
um my opinion Tim not far off that
there are some challenges that on you
yeah
um you are competing with a broader
competence hierarchy there are more men
competing for all women there are more
women competing for all men as well uh
and on top of that the landscape
generally has changed what people expect
has changed the fact that there is
basically an endless number of options
means that everyone is always going to
be nexting right just looking over the
shoulder of who they're with to see if
somebody better is going to come down
the line whereas if you're in a village
with 200 people in it there's 10 that
are available and your age
so yeah perhaps
um
who's got a longer morning routine you
or Ben Greenfield uh that would be Ben
Greenfield I think mine has been
stripped back it used to be 90 minutes
and now it's much closer to 40 40
minutes or so get up walk
breath work
meditate read
start writing that's the order
petrub 1984 why the Crocs why not the
Crocs petrob that's the question that I
want to ask I am a complete Croc convert
as far as I can see they are
pretty close to an elite
type of Footwear the perfect two-car
garage for me would be Crocs and vans
comfy Kush vans
so you know also for traveling in
unbelievable
Rich Thurston I wonder if this is Mike's
brother Mike thurston's brother I think
is called Richard
if comparison is the thief of joy to
what extent can influences perpetuate
slash prevent this P.S thanks for the Q
jump back in 2012 on it last all of my
mate okay
um
my pleasure uh I I don't remember it
either but if comparison is the thief of
joy to what extent can influencers
perpetuate slash prevent this that's a
really great question that
um
for each influencer who decides to
position or posit this beautiful
aspirational life other people are then
going to start measuring themselves off
that and
it's going to cause pain given the fact
that we are more exposed to this than
ever before that means that more
comparison could equal people feeling
less and less competent that they are
further and further away from what they
would should could be
um to what extent can influencers
prevent this is a great question and I
think being more open honest vulnerable
um
helps to
mediate this I have the perfect
beautiful Instagram life and all I do is
drink cocktails in the Maldives and stay
in single-digit body fat and nothing
ever phases me
opening up a little bit more honestly
around the challenges that you've got in
life and all of the times that you fail
helps to humanize you and it helps an
audience to resonate with what it is
that you're saying like no one's perfect
dude I've been around
some of the best known people on the
planet for the last 15 years right like
whether it be reality TV people sports
stars singers whatever and now the
YouTube and content creation World
everyone's got [__] going on behind the
scenes everybody does
it's
important I think for people to open up
as much as they can this doesn't mean
you know talking about your chronic
flatulence or your athlete's foot or
whatever but opening up as much as you
can uh helps because it humanizes the
people that are up there and it also
um
it means that the world's uh asymmetry
or that
um how do you say like status despite a
Perfection disparity right the
Perfection disparity between the two is
is a little bit less
Wales 92 how do you deal with the rapid
growth of the podcast Subs absolutely
amazing work thank you very much um yeah
this is also a really good question
because I have felt
um a bit of a difference over the last
few months uh specifically probably the
last six which is more attention and
more scrutiny and more eyes and
obviously you know you do a thing that
you care about and you hope that it's
successful and you hope that people also
care about it but all of the attention
you get isn't necessarily good and you
didn't ask for that not good attention
you just wanted the people that like the
stuff that you do but as you grow you'd
start to reach out into the real
internet like the Fiat 500 uh Instagram
internet and the more that you do that
the
more that you start to suck in people
who maybe have an ax to grind who aren't
part of the core community and again I I
think you know credit to the fact that
this is a whatever 800 and something
thousand person YouTube channel and
almost every single comment is
reasonable well-balanced well thought
out and even now people who do comment
stuff that is totally unhinged get fact
checked by other people who've obviously
listened to the show for longer and are
more reasonable and say that's what are
you talking about like that's not that
that's not the way that you behave
basically so I'm very very proud proud
of it but it is making me
not ambiently anxious but I'm more aware
of it uh and I think I'm going to have
to maybe get some more advice uh from
guys that are further ahead than me
about how to deal with that attention as
it continues to grow
Ian davidson39501
thoughts on Patrick rothfuss's
kingkiller Trilogy will we ever see part
three Doors of Stone I love those first
two books if you need a fantasy uh Duo
it's supposed to be a trilogy but the
third one isn't out yet uh it's
fantastic I absolutely adore it
it seems to be a game of who will write
the book last between
George RR Martin and Patrick rothfuss at
the moment and I really hope that both
of them just get it done because they're
both getting older and I want to see how
it ends but yeah King killer Trilogy if
anybody needs a new fantasy series go
and check out the first two books
they're awesome
Burke why did you start and stop Mai Tai
I started because I was bored of
bodybuilding and
bro bro lift split style training I
needed something new to do and
it was just the right time I'd always
done martial arts as a kid I'd done uh
Lao GAO Kung Fu to brown sash and a
bunch of other stuff
but
it was only ever going to be a bit of a
stop gap for me because
when I got back to the UK I lost a ton
of weight because I was doing it out in
Thailand
and I didn't like the way that I felt I
preferred being heavier like I just feel
better when I'm a heavier guy and I
wasn't able to hold on to any mass at
all whilst training I very well may
start some striking up again I do little
bits here and there maybe once every
month or something just dick about but
yeah it was fun
music just thinking about death make you
braver calmer in your everyday life
let's see what crispot has to say okay
Chris bot
does thinking about death make you
braver calmer in your everyday life
I think the following about death can be
a powerful reminder to live life to the
fullest and make the most of every
moment it can also help to put things
into perspective and help us to
prioritize what's important ultimately
it can help us to be braver and calmer
in our everyday lives Chris but that is
that's just saying the question back to
you
um I have to say my real Chris his
opinion is I don't spend that much time
meditating on death I know that I should
do I know that it would be good to
remind me that I have a limited amount
of time left here
I don't think about it enough for it to
for me to be able to say what sort of an
effect it has but when I do spend time
in nature and I'm made to feel small
because of the grandness of the night
sky or an awesome tree or you know some
beautiful animals or whatever uh it does
make me feel more connected and braver
and calmer so
maybe I should do it more
uh Cameron Dix what was the best thing
being bullied did two slash for you
weirdly phrased I know
let's see if Chris Buck can answer this
one let's get rid of the weirdly phrased
bit did two
or for you
come on Chris bot
being bullied taught me the importance
of resilience and standing up for myself
it also helped me to develop empathy and
compassion for others who are going
through similar experiences it was a
difficult time but ultimately made me a
stronger more understanding person
not far off is quite diplomatic is Chris
bot but I'm glad he's doing that as
opposed to being a raving bigot uh I
would say the best thing that it did to
me was gave me comfort in being on my
own that I have absolutely no concern
about working in solitude living in
solitude
dropping my entire life at 33 and moving
out to America
um
it's a double-edged sword right A lot of
the things that you dislike the most in
yourself at the Dark Side of something
that you really appreciate and for me
you know I
have always wished I was more
extroverted I always wished that I was
able to socialize more easily
um and yet I also take a lot of pride in
the fact that I can work on my own and I
don't necessarily need a ton of support
around me to just keep on getting things
done and pursue toward goals and
developments that I like so
it's both sides of it
Alan wickstead have you any tips on
recovering from a long period of
procrastination slash low mood slash
inefficiency have you made many
improvements to personal health but the
thoughts of opening the laptop and
getting [__] done is too much sometimes
yeah so this is
um there's an interesting quote from
Stephen pressfield in the war of Art and
he says a real writer knows that the
writing part that writing isn't the hard
part it's sitting down to right that's
hard and his point is that almost all of
the inertia occurs at the very very
beginning
tips for recovering from a long period
of procrastination low mood and
inefficiency is focus on biology first
so huberman says you cannot change the
mind to the mind you have to change it
with the body it's not strictly true
because of meditation but I do think
that he's right get moving get up at the
same time enough hydration sunlight hot
cold train spend time with friends like
you need that base of just good feels
and then on top of that you can start to
build anything that you want to do which
is more abstract
I would say
set yourself the smallest Target that
you can do it before you do anything
else ideally before you touch your phone
first thing in the morning and a win
would be 10 minutes of whatever the work
is that you're doing okay 10 minutes is
good another thing you could use the
zygonic effect which is
um leaving a sentence if you are let's
say it's writing or whatever leaving a
sentence half finished when you complete
your work session for the day which
means that when you begin to restart the
next day you're not beginning from a
full stop you'll be getting halfway
through a sentence and you know who
can't finish the sentence everyone can
finish the sentence Oh but then I've
written half a sentence and then I've
written another one and then we're into
the flow so those are some things that
work for me especially given that I'm
writing a lot at the moment
doing something you love or doing
something that pays well okay Chris bot
let's not be such a Swiss Diplomat with
this one okay
I think it's important to have a balance
between doing something you love
fucksake and doing something that pays
well it's important to find a job you
enjoy that pays you enough to support
yourself and your family that way you
can have a fulfilling career and still
have financial securities pursue your
passions
I would personally say that because the
question says doing something that pays
well not something that pays adequately
do something that you love because again
you're going to look back in 20 years
time and all of the money that you earn
between now and then you would probably
give to have this time back so you might
as well optimize for enjoying the time
as opposed to earning as much money as
possible once you get over that base
it's marginal gains all the way up it
seems like around about sort of seventy
thousand eighty thousand dollars about
sixty sixty thousand pounds is a limit
beyond that each doubling of money seems
to give you an increase in satisfaction
but it's you know it's 140 then it's 280
then it's 560. you know it's an
increasingly large amount to get a small
dose of of Life satisfaction
uh so yeah I would say do something that
you love uh and then you're always going
to be better at that thing in any case
and if you fail there are always always
going to be jobs that you hate that
wouldn't pay well waiting for you on the
other side of it add vet what's a core
value that guides your life right this
this is more direct I feel like this is
Chris Bots
right in his wheelhouse
one of the core values that guides my
life is to always strive for growth and
Improvement I believe that we should
never stop learning and growing that we
should always be open to new ideas and
perspectives this helps me to stay
motivated and to push keep pushing
myself to be the best version of myself
a bit of repetition there Chris but uh
not far off
um for me curiosity is just the most
effective one and
the reason is that
it's so inbuilt in me and it keeps my
ego small and it helps me focus on
satisfying my
innate desire to learn and that always
guides me towards stuff which is
satisfying and useful because if it
wasn't interesting to me it wouldn't do
either of those things and the
presumption is that if I find it
useful and interesting maybe some
non-insignificant cohort of other people
will do too and that's the hope for what
happens with all of you guys
dot me what are your favorite references
for solo monologue type podcasts
I don't know what you mean there when I
do the lessons type podcast that is
usually coming from me
um taking my favorite learnings from
newsletters that I've done which you can
sign up for at chriswillx.com books
um and I use Apple notes if you're
looking for the structure it's always
Apple notes will Connolly chances of you
getting Chris Brown on the podcast after
he shared you on his story yeah Chris
Brown shared a video of me quoting
homozy to whole Mosey and then quoting a
land about onto her Mosey to like 150
million people the other day didn't
expect C Breezy to be into bro
philosophy but
here we are uh chances of me getting him
on the podcast I don't know would anyone
be interested in Chris Brown he's
massive time but I I don't know what
like other than being you know a very
successful Performing Artist and having
a history with Rihanna I don't really
know what he's done but maybe I guess
the Rufus what was your experience on
Diary of a CEO like so we go tons of
questions about that Instagram reel and
and this Diary of a CEO thing
uh I really enjoyed it it was an intense
period because I'd been with homozy in
Vegas the day before
two days before and then went for dinner
with Stephen the night before we
recorded for five hours until God knows
what time got up the next day packed
ready to go recorded diary of the CEO
and went from there to LAX to fly from
LA to Qatar 16 hours direct so it was
kind of a whirlwind
um
the operation that Steve's got there
despite the fact that we kind of do the
same thing the uh daily experience of
what's going on is very different for
both of us you know Steven's got a
really sophisticated team which is very
enviable uh and like it's a machine to
watch
um so that definitely gave me a little
bit of a nudge to say look perhaps you
should relinquish a little bit of
control you don't need to do
every single thing because Stephen is
able to
farm that out to other people that are
competent and good at what they do and
his life hasn't come crashing down
around him so
the operational side of things was
interesting uh seems a good interviewer
you know we've known each other for
quite a long time
um and he gives a lot of space which I
enjoy uh you don't ever feel rushed
which is good
uh the recreation of his
like house Studio thing in La was
hilarious so I enjoyed seeing how that
worked and we spoke about all of the
stuff that I'm interested in we spoke
about uh you know the sort of whole bro
philosophy stuff insights about life
lessons that I've learned
mating problems challenges for guys
challenges for girls
um and it's performing really really
well which is which is nice like it's
it's good when new people hear things
that they're maybe unfamiliar with and
it opens their eyes and um you know for
every single person that is here off the
back of that episode welcome
designs by Jesse how do you use your
knowledge from your podcasts in your
personal life I try and apply it as much
as possible because mental masturbation
is not particularly good for anyone and
if you are very much in your head just
constantly being cerebral you can end up
having that happen
an awful lot
um
trying to think how can I apply this
does this grow any corn as I said on
Steven's show
show me how I can use this what how does
this impact my daily actions uh seems to
be a good prompt and it works for me but
it's difficult like you know there's way
way more knowledge than there is time to
apply it and memory capacity to remember
the thing that you're supposed to apply
so stuff
add ham zero eight seven seven are you
planning on getting Jonathan height to
the show let's ask Chris bot again Chris
bot
are you planning on getting Jonathan
height to the show
I would love to have Jonathan Heights on
the show he is an incredibly insightful
thinker and I'm sure he would have a lot
of valuable insights to share I'm
definitely looking into it and hopefully
I can make it happen soon looks like
Jonathan height is also coming on the
show thanks Chris but I wonder if
there's anyone that Chris but let's see
this would you bring
bring Hitler on the podcast
no I would not bring Hitler on the
podcast Chris bott's got spine
I like this guy
um
we have found that somewhere in between
Iman Ghazi Jonathan height and Hitler is
a line that crispot will not cross so
let us keep going
uh hi Chris what is one piece of advice
you would give to your younger self 10
years ago okay let's try let's see if
Chris Buck can come up with this he's
already
really stuck his flag in the ground
about Hitler
hi Chris what is one piece of advice you
would give to your younger self 10 years
ago one piece of advice I would give to
my younger self 10 years ago is to take
more risks and be more open to new
experiences life is short and it's
important to take chances and try new
things don't be afraid to take risks and
step outside of your comfort zone not
far off uh that would definitely be one
of them
probably just have faith
that everything's going to be fine
because I operate a lot of the time from
I have operated from a place of fear
um scarcity concern that
I'm gonna look stupid or that everything
is going to come crashing down or it's
all going to fall apart or you know the
sort of rampant imposter syndrome thing
um
nothing really I it that didn't improve
my performance none of that almost none
of it uh I contributed to getting from
where I was to where I am so I could
have gotten rid of all of it and just
enjoyed the experience more so I think
fearing less would have would have
probably been a good piece of advice
almost everybody that's listening to
this is going to be absolutely fine no
matter what they face every single
challenge that you have come up against
up to now you have surpassed by virtue
of you being here the fact that you are
sat here listening to this means that
you've survived
so therefore why would you presume that
all of the things that you fear right
now have any validity either
they probably don't
uh Medusa WTF are opinionated women less
attractive
Ah that's interesting our opinionated
women less attractive I would say
very dependent on what opinion it is
like if it's a strongly opinionated
woman about the Jews maybe more
difficult to to get turned on
um
opinionated women less I I don't think
it mediates attraction massively it's
not strongly opinion it's just
opinionated no I would say no
opinionated women no women who have
absolutely no opinion at all are so
passive that they basically become like
a maid you want something right you need
you're having a conversation and if what
do you think about this what's your
opinion on such and such and it's just
if there's never any response
what are you going to be attracted to
like you're not having a conversation
it's like speaking to a mirror or an
empty room I suppose strongly
opinionated women I guess sometimes that
might be correlated with high
disagreeability
that to me is less attractive I highly
disagreeable women for some of my
friends they love that kind of spark and
that kind of push back and push and pull
type thing that's not my bag but for
some people it is on average I would say
opinionated women
relatively neutral very heavily
opinionated women sometimes Maybe
less good
find the catch lights male slash female
relations divide grow further
or do you expect a positive Tipping
Point when I think this is Will male and
female relation The Divide between men
and women and their relations grow
further or do you expect a positive
Tipping Point
another really great question I would
say
I would like to think that it's going to
turn around
um this is heavily going to be mediated
by what people learn I think that the
way that we go about our
um relationships increasingly I'm
believing the fact that the way we go
about our relationships is mimetic so we
we see the way that other people behave
we see the sorts of behavior that we
believe is acceptable by the kinds of
behavior that other people do around us
and then we model that for what we want
in our relationship and what you end up
with is kind of like an a curve that
goes either up or curve that goes down
almost like the kovid r number because
as more of one particular type of
relationship occurs publicly you get
more people emulating that which shows
more people which shows more people and
so on and so on
um
I don't know to be honest I at the
moment it could go either way
um
I'm not massively I'm not today I've
woken up and I'm not feeling massively
confident about it other days I do feel
a little bit more confident but today
I think that there needs to be a rather
large cultural
flash point
um almost like
and not like a reverse me too but but
like kind of like how me too sort of
captured the culture so much but
something that brings everybody together
and makes them realize that you're not
supposed to be each other's adversaries
that women should care about men falling
behind that men should care about women
feeling lonely and retreating into into
careers and and the challenge of
blending a career with with maybe
wanting to be a mother but then not
being sure if that's just the patriarchy
conning them into it
all of that kind of needs to happen and
it really needs to happen right now so
that's the plan that's what would fix it
um whether or not it's going to happen
anytime soon I don't know but it can't
keep going like this for much longer or
else
we're going to be so far apart that no
one can ever have a conversation again
uh Kami dot Brown do you think growing
up in a working class environment has
been more of a plus than a negative I
would personally say that it's been a
massive plus to me it's helped to keep
my feet on the ground it's meant that I
basically have no materialistic desires
at all
um I
in terms of the negatives of it you
don't understand just how Grand your
plans could be I I'm I'm never going to
build a business or or grow a company to
the size of somebody who was around
completely unbounded Blue Sky helicopter
thinking belief entrepreneurs you know
the parents spent all of their time with
them between the ages of 5 and 20 or
something because I I just I don't have
that fundamental model but I think from
a personal level it actually helps you
to be much more satisfied with a much
lower level of materialistic success
um so yeah I you know there are
positives and minuses on both sides I
would say personally that I'm glad that
I had the working class upbringing that
I did
Craig pollitt do you agree with Stephen
pinker's claims that now is the best
time in human history I'm going to ask
Chris Bott does he know who Stephen
Pinker is does he understand that it's
the best time in human history I think
Stephen Pinker makes some valid points
but I don't necessarily agree with his
overall claim that now is the best time
in human history interesting there are
still many challenges and injustices oh
dear that need to be addressed and I
think it's important to recognize that
while there have been some improvements
there is still a lot of work to be done
Chris but went woke there a little
didn't he injustices challenges and
injustices there are challenges and
injustices but yeah it's it's
objectively by far the best time to live
in human history however think about the
base of Maslow's hierarchy of needs if
you've got all of the bottom stuff the
food the shelter the social connection
sorted even if it's through social media
you actually have the opportunity to
deal with an existential crisis no
caveman thirty thousand years ago was
wondering whether he was enacting his
logos forward and speaking his truth
contributing to the universe and the
astral realm in the best way possible
because he was worried that he was going
to be killed or stabbed or freezed to
death tomorrow night
oddly an existential crisis is a
luxurious position to be in it's just
not one that is necessarily often given
a whole lot of sympathy it's like oh
poor little comfortable 21st century
people complaining about the fact that
they can't enact their logos and and you
know Master their Universe properly
it is still difficult like getting to
that stage of development is one that
very few humans have had to deal with
before so we don't have a massive amount
or don't have as an equivalent amount of
advice on what to do when you get there
so
from a foundational perspective yes best
time to exist in human history by far
medical advances safety from climate etc
etc etc
psychologically
actually probably coming off the other
side of that oh maybe
maybe actually now I'm thinking about
maybe 20 years ago was better
I wonder whether
again this is on average are you talking
about places that are extreme profit
poverty for people that are mostly
listening to this podcast I would maybe
be tempted to say that
was perhaps a a slightly more
psychologically stable time than now
that is wild to think that to think that
it might have been better 20 years ago
that's that's the first time I've ever
thought of that interesting uh
Bradley ronmac will you ever be a
pickleball world champion uh no I won't
but I'm good friends with Zane navratil
who is the current
number three ranked men's player in the
world uh and I've tried to play him on
the courts just over there and the guy's
unplayable the difference the chasm
between me a casual recreational
pickleball player and him is
unbelievably vast so I'm going to say no
[Music]
will you invite Posey Parker to Modern
wisdom this is the lady who has been
involved in a bunch of
kind of like protests and riots in
Australia at the moment I think she's
doing some stuff to do with feminism uh
I'm not familiar with her work uh but I
am kind of interested in learning more
stuff about her I feel like I've got in
my S watch later playlist on YouTube I
feel like I've got more stuff from her
uh CL I just want to say thank you I've
watched some of your videos and had a
really good discussion afterward with my
teenage son it's helped me understand
the world as he sees it
that's very cool
that's awesome thank you uh I love how
diverse the people that listen to the
show is as well uh it's that's really
great and if your son is you know even
taking one percent of the best stuff
that comes from the show I'm sure that
he's going to be an absolute Killer Mike
congratulations Chris what are the steps
you went through to build your Social
Circle or that you would follow now if
you were to start from nothing at 20 how
about 30 or 40. okay so I'm going to
Chris bought this but we'll just do it
from 20. what are the steps that you
went through come on Chris Bart let's
give us an interesting one
of the steps that you went through to
build your
if I were to start from nothing at 20 I
would focus on building relationships
with people who share similar interests
and values I would also try to get
involved in activities and organizations
that I'm passionate about this is a good
way to meet like-minded people
additionally I would make an effort to
be open and friendly to everyone I meet
as this can help to build strong
connections finally I would make sure to
stay in touch with the people I meet and
nurture those relationships over time
that's not bad that's not bad from Chris
Paul especially the last thing which is
to keep in touch um
I went to places that had people in that
were like the sort of people that I
wanted to be friends with so I wanted to
be friends with people that did Fitness
so I started doing CrossFit I wanted to
be friends with people that uh read and
were into sort of rationality and
existential risk so I joined the
lesserong community out here in Austin
um keeping in touch is a really really
important point because it's not just
about meeting someone it's about keeping
on top of that and you would not believe
how many people suck
super hard
at maintaining friendships even if you
meet somebody and then just drop a
message a couple of days later hey man
great to meet you if you fancy going for
coffee next week it's not going to work
every single time but it makes such a
huge difference and it means that over
time you will start to grow that Social
Circle out and that's been a big help
for me so
seven out of ten response from Chris
bottler
OG listeners are fortunate enough to
know your original motivations behind
the podcast but as you reach almost 1
million subscribers speak to guests with
their own content uh contentions and get
clipped down into endless short film
videos what do you think a new
subscriber might misunderstand about
your motivations or your character what
gets Lost in Translation amongst the
masses that is an elite question
what do you think a new subscriber might
misunderstand about your motivations or
your character so it's kind of what I
said before like I'm way too blue pilled
and in the eyes of the manosphere
community it's like I'm just cooking for
women because I'm playing the
politically correct collect correct role
because I I can't wait to get like a
hosting slot on [__] Channel 4 or
something and then for somebody that
comes from a more left-leaning
perspective or someone that is part of
The 500 Club or a guardian reader I'm
gonna look like a raving misogynist
bigot budget Andrew Tate so
um I think there are a lot of ways that
people could misunderstand this if you
are getting clipped down into endless
short form videos that being said
I I honestly feel like the conversations
that I have on the show are it would be
struggle it would be hard for me to be
more reasonable it'd be hard for me to
find guests that come on under more
caveat I feel like I'm finding the line
of where guests say things where I'm
like hang on a second like is that
really what you think do we need to play
devil's advocate here have you got a
reference for that
um
I would Hazard a guess that given the
fact that the difference between the
comments on Instagram and the comments
on YouTube specifically on the Diary of
a CEO podcast YouTube people that have
maybe either watched the full thing or
heard what I've done before
interpreted it it saw a different person
sort of different video right to what
they saw on Instagram
um but this is what I was saying before
that
the more content that gets put out there
the more opportunities there are for
people to misinterpret uh misconstrue
artificially uh manipulate what it is
that you've done or said and claim that
that is you right they're saying that
this is the tip of the iceberg and you
don't know the bigoted raving racist or
whatever it is that's that's lurking
below the depths
Tate said
that he realized as his platform grew
that he had to be more careful about the
things that he said because it reaches
more people which basically gives it a
greater opportunity to be misconstrued
so maybe you do need to just be more
precise as you keep on growing but at
the moment you know I I'm really really
happy with how everything has gone I'm
confident that at some point within the
next few years there will be some
sentence that falls out of my mouth that
I say in a a bumbled way that is taken
in a bad a bad manner but you go okay
there's a thousand hours behind me of me
not being the raving like
jew-hating misogynist or whatever that
I'm being accused of
probably easier to presume that it was
an error or imprecise speech than me
finally unveiling my KKK membership
Geordie Shaw hi Chris you mentioned to
read more articles on sub stack you
mentioned you read more articles on
substack than books these days can you
share your top sub stack articles you
must read before you die list I might
put this together I might do an article
list uh as a addition to the reading
list certainly sub Stacks that you
should check out Rob Henderson's is
fantastic gwynda bogles is fantastic
um astral codex 10
uh
uh by Scott Alexander is great
experimental history by Adam mastriani
is also great and pirate wires by Mike
Solana all great reads
Andrea with the bangs you've mentioned
the idea that words and declarations
mean more than actions in the age of
social media what does this mean to you
how do you prioritize practicing What
You Preach in your own life this is kind
of the same as what I said before that
you can do the mental masturbation thing
and come out on the other side realizing
that you've learned an awful lot and
enacted basically nothing
um
I try as best I can to live out the
strategies that I care about I'm so far
from perfect right I I literally
couldn't be further from perfect but the
bar is set so high like perfect is
beyond unreachable
um prioritizing practicing what I preach
is just how can I apply this does it
grow corn what does this look like when
I try and take it and make it actionable
and this is the same with everything
that you that you learn
if you just allow all of the content to
come over you to watch over you and then
eventually you're going to hear
something that goes oh holy [__] I can't
not see that I can't and see it okay
build the Habit around that one don't
try and force The Habit on the thing
that sounds like you should do it but
you have absolutely no desire to
think about the thing that hits you
through the heart you go I roll over and
spend 45 minutes every single night
checking my phone before I go to bed
okay practice that
put it outside of your room or I do you
know X Y and Z whatever it is take the
thing that resonates apply it as hard as
you can
don't miss two days in a row there's a
rule
uh uh Greg Lunt how big is your team and
in what areas are you looking to expand
let's see if Chris Bott knows how big
the team is
foreign
my team currently consists of myself my
video editor Dean and a few of the
people who help with the podcast and
other projects we're looking to expand
our team in the areas of content
creation marketing and social media uh
he's got our briskies he knew about Dean
that's good
a few of the people who help with the
podcast that will be Ben we just brought
on a new guy called Chase he is looking
after some of the YouTube stuff uh and I
would love to get a business manager and
a producer on because it would make life
an awful lot easier Adam question will
people stop buying books now you can
just listen to podcasts with the author
going into greater detail about the book
I find myself doing this a lot I would
say
yes to degree
but when you do listen to an author
where you know even a three-hour
conversation only scratches the surface
of a book
there will be times where you just have
to go out and buy it and this is why you
know the podcast tours for authors are
being so successful because it is the
front end of their funnel it's capturing
people with cool stuff and then they dig
down and watch more
Mark cushion two guests I'd really like
to see in the show True Geordie and
Darren Brown any chance so me and Brian
true Jody have been talking for quite a
while
I think
it's we'll probably do something before
the end of the year Darren Brown I would
absolutely love to bring him on I think
he's fascinating but I don't have an in
with him yet so
hold on tight
Jason Brady do you think homozy is the
naval of his generation I think Naval is
the naval of his generation homozy is a
really really impressive operator I love
the Bro philosophy stuff I love the fact
that he's got real world applicable
evidence that he's done these things
that he's not just laughing about it and
he's not just doing the mental
masturbation thing
but
Naval is a different breed of human he
is his insights are phenomenal and I
really
I very much miss him being more active
on the sort of content creation circuit
but hopefully that'll change and if it
does I will be sat here waiting waiting
for him waiting to to pounce with an
email
fit and Nancy looking back how did you
make it so big and so quick in the
podcast world I don't think I did
man like it's taken
half a decade and 600 and something
episodes to get to really even a
remotely appreciable size where anybody
cares about what I'm doing
um so I I don't think I have made it
very quick there are people whose
Ascension has been basically vertical
Brett Cooper
um launched the podcast or launched her
Channel a year ago a year and a couple
of months ago and she's at two million
Subs
um but I don't
I don't not care like I love the fact
that the show is growing and I love the
fact that people resonate with what I
care about but nothing's changed me and
Dean always felt like the podcast was
undersubscribed because the
conversations that we were having were
sometimes very different to what you
could get because I was finding people
that to me were personally interesting
and they weren't doing the circuit so
because nothing's ever changed it's very
strange that what we do is the same
thing it's the same Facebook Messenger
thread that we talk backward and forward
on about
thumbnail amends and and what guests are
coming up and stuff uh the only thing
that's changed is the fact that we've
done it for so long that there's now
this Army of of people that watch
um
the most important things that have
happened in terms of growth if that's
the question are just being consistent
being consistent finding big guests
having good conversations uh and and
getting better at doing the craft which
happens because you've done it
consistently
that guy Pete you refused to invite to
Gatherings I've seen Pete comment on a
bunch of different episodes and his
comments usually are pretty good
how has deep diving into evolutionary
psychology affected how you navigate
relationships in real life
true to form that guy Pete
good question let's see what Chris Bott
says how is deep diving into
evolutionary psychology affected how you
navigate relationships in real life
exploring evolutionary psychology has
helped me to better understand
underlying motivations behind human
behavior good this has enabled me to
better navigate relationships in real
life by being more aware of the
underlying dynamics of play okay it has
also helped me to be more mindful of my
own behavior and to be more conscious of
how my actions might affected this that
was a bit of [__]
um
it is
difficult in some regards like I said
before there is a period where you don't
see people as people you see them as
just a collection of inputs and and
signals and incentives that are kind of
like manipulating them like a marionette
on strings
um and that's a little disconcerting
because
you start to see code instead of seeing
Matrix and
it can
feel disquieting
um manipulative in a way not that you're
necessarily being manipulative but when
you start to
deconstruct why people do the things
that they do
it takes you out of just the enjoyment
or the natural sensation of just being
with the person doing the thing always
asking that question even if you asked
it before now having the answer kind of
it's jarring so you know for the people
that are into the EP stuff I think that
this is just a price that you have to
pay uh there's that a London bottom
quote the one that Chris Brown shared uh
loneliness is the kind of tax you have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind I wonder whether
discordance is a kind of tax you have to
pay to atone for a certain depth of
evolutionary psychology insight
we will see
elves have you ever or would you ever
record a podcast and dislike how it went
enough to not post it you know I've
never been asked this question before
and I thought that this would be
something that would have come up there
are a bunch of podcasts that I've
recorded that have never seen the light
of day most of the time it is because
the guest just wasn't having a
particularly good day for one reason or
another and
my goal is to keep producing content
that I would listen to if I ask myself
would I listen to this podcast would I
enjoy listening to this podcast and the
answer is no
I'm asking for a lot from you even at
two-time speed you know you're still
giving me 45 minutes of your day
um
I can't I in all good conscience I can't
put out an episode that doesn't
it doesn't add value and if it doesn't
make the guest look good because you
know they were they weren't performing
particularly well what
it's it's not a positive for them to
reach you know cumulative couple of
million followers across all platforms
burbling and bumbling and stumbling over
their words
stoicism underscore enjoyer I'm 13. holy
[__] okay what should I do with my life
what books to read what business to
start watching my main focus be PS big
fan of your podcast since 80 000 Subs
mind-blowing to see if 10x so quickly
I we were at 80 000 Subs
three years ago two years ago
three two and a half years ago we were
80 000 Subs so you've been listening
since you were
11.
or 10.
what should I do with my life at 13.
um look I don't want to be patronizing I
I think that you're asking the right
questions which is very important but I
think that just getting on with sinking
into the experience of being a human all
of the main learnings that you're going
to get are going to come from
socializing interacting with other
people having real world experiences I
would spend as little time as possible
on the internet I would spell as little
time as possible on your phone and on
social media
I would find it I mean you you sound you
sound like you're [__] 21. stoicism
enjoyer so I would maybe try and hang
out with some people that are a little
bit older than you they're going to be
on your level
um I you do not need to start a business
at age 13. it would be cool if you could
maybe there's something that you can see
um where you have access and you can
leverage the fact that you are so much
further ahead at such a younger age if
you were to start a business I would be
looking at something that you have a
specific piece of technical advantage in
um so Insight around what other 13 year
olds want at this age and then how can I
get this out onto the internet leverage
it you need something that isn't going
to cost a lot so a digital course would
be great
um you don't want to really be doing
Drop Shipping and like I mean or sending
a bunch of fidget Spinners to your
parents house so that you can try and
sell them in school trying to Arbitrage
bottles of prime I wouldn't focus on
that uh but dude I mean you're asking
questions that are the people that are
literally twice your age haven't asked
themselves so keep on thinking deeply
focus on enjoying life hasn't have as
many experiences as possible in terms of
books to read
um essentialism by Greg McEwen way of
the superior man by uh David data Atomic
Habits by James Clear probably something
to do with health and fitness which
would be great
um
the Align method by Aaron Alexander
Kelly starrett's new built to move Peter
attia's new outlive business to start
something online watching my main focus
be just enjoy life bro you don't get
like like child years back so
keep listening to Modern wisdom but
other than that get off the internet
enjoy life and you are going to be an
absolute killer in no time at all
uh night league did you ever think you
would become a famous million sub
YouTuber on your first day starting your
channel uh the First first day starting
my channel was in 2017
um we recorded a failed episode that
never never went out when the podcast
was called mind and matter
um I I had no idea what was going to
happen and
I always wanted to just have interesting
conversations and now there's just more
people watching so
I have no complaints little broomstick
how much of the current toxic elements
of the pillar sphere
pilosphere manosphere do you believe are
attributable to young men being left out
of dating and sexual relationships early
as teenage and young men I 13 to 25
before men enter Prime earnings I don't
quite understand
men being left out of dating and sexual
relationships okay so is the fact that
younger guys aged eight uh 13 to 25 are
having less dating and sexual encounters
contributing to the proliferation of red
pill black pill Etc and the manosphere
stuff yeah perhaps I think you know a
good part of what's going on with
mgtow black pill in cell culture red
pill manosphere high value low value man
and then on the other side sort of Boss
[__] leaning culture R female dating
strategy
um all of like that Trad wife all of
those movements right on both sides
maybe slightly less Trad wife
um what's happening is these are copes
from both sides of the aisle on we are
struggling in The Mating Market we need
to find a solution for it the solution
is band together of the shared hatred of
an out group usually point the finger at
the other sex
um so yeah actually
it's certainly the toxic elements of it
um would be
eased an awful lot if young guys were
having real world interactions with
women because they would realize that
it's not the
the group of girls that the internet
tells you are out there waiting for you
to hijack all of your earnings and run
off with your brother and your left leg
then they're very very difficult to find
the problem is that because not many
guys have got real world experience to
just disprove that
how are they going to actually have any
advice other than what they've read on
the internet so yeah I think that might
be right
fit Barber YYC what's it like living
with a maniac like Zach calendar Zach is
fantastic to live with we get on very
very well he is a great influence on me
and he
helps to keep me upbeat and positive and
I think that I help to make him nice and
and focused so it's not as maniacal as
you might think Xavier can you please
invite Lex Friedman Lex came to my
birthday a couple of weeks ago uh that
Michael malice did at his house which is
very nice of him and he will be on the
show eventually the guy is busy he's
trying to make robots to save the world
and and automate his lunch or whatever
it is he's doing big things so it'll
happen it's just a case of one wake up
what's the number one bad habit that has
held you back for the longest time this
sounds like a good Chris bot question
what's the number one bad habit that's
how do you bank for the longest time
the number one bad habit that's held me
back for the longest time is
procrastination I often find myself
putting off tasks and projects until the
last minute which can lead to stress and
poor quality work I'm working on
becoming more mindful of my time and
making sure I'm taking action on the
things that are important to me I would
have said probably my phone phone does
cause me to procrastinate but just phone
use I I don't like how much time I spend
on my phone I wish I didn't
I don't spend you know forever out I
don't know what my average screen time
is per day but it's more than I want and
the story that I tell myself around my
phone use is also like that sucks it's
not good
array honest opinion of Dubai ever see
yourself living there Chris bot come on
let's
do this honest opinion of Dubai ever see
yourself living there
I think Dubai is an amazing city with a
lot to offer it's a great place to visit
and explore and I could definitely see
myself living there one day culture and
architecture are fascinating the city
has a lot of energy and vibrancy yeah I
think it's a good place to live and work
and I would love to experience it for
myself one day I've been I've been
crispart I've been [__] tons of times
uh I could see myself living there but
it would probably mostly be for the tax
um to be honest
it's great for short trips but starting
a family there probably not there isn't
a massive amount of sort of nature or at
least nature in the way that I not
unless you think that sand is nature
um it's not very
how do you say appropriate for dogs and
a big dog person
I really like it and a lot of my friends
that are out there are loving it but I
don't think they're probably going to
settle down there so I could see myself
living there for a short period of time
but in terms of settling down for
forever home probably not
uh benth seven have you ever suffered
with anxiety or depression
come on Chris bot this is a nice upfront
question for you to ask yes I've
suffered with anxiety and depression in
the past it was a difficult time I was
able to get through it with the help of
therapy and medication
this is just a lie I'm afraid I'm now in
a much better place and I'm grateful for
the support I received
didn't do really any therapy never been
medicated so crispot is
he's having a bad day so far uh I have
suffered with anxiety and depression
mostly depression throughout my 20s
um
this rough man like you know being
ashamed about the fact that you feel
sad and you have nothing to feel sad
about was the worst part of it so you
know my depression would manifest by me
being in bed bound for you know a few
days at a time maybe once every few
months and because I was the owner
director of my own company no one could
tell me where I needed to be I could
make excuses I could get other people to
go and do stuff for me and then it would
usually happen
in between two appointments or or events
or whatever where I actually had to be
there where I couldn't not be there and
I would just spend this time lying bed
eat [__] food not open the curtains not
want to do anything
um I hate myself
like just real real low mood and it
would happen consistently like a lot
throughout my 20s
um sleep pattern was a massive massive
contributor to that and fixing the sleep
pattern fixed an awful lot of everything
that happened Downstream
um
I always thought I was depressed for
a good chunk of it turned out I was
heavily heavily sleep deprived and then
a bunch of other things too
um but
it's it's not it's not fun uh and I'm
very very glad that I'm in a place now
where
there's still that that that person's
still in me
um but the voice and the tenor of them
are much more quiet
um I do sometimes wonder
What will What would happen what will
happen uh if I enter one of those stages
while I've still got the show to do and
if I've got to you know turn up and try
and have a conversation with somebody
maybe it's a big guest or maybe it
I don't know I I don't ever want to come
and put on a face and pretend that
everything's fine and dandy in my own
life to you guys because I've tried to
be really truthful and open and
vulnerable but I also don't want to be
the guy that comes on and goes hey mate
how's everything going today and me to
respond to the guest and say that I hate
myself and and I I spent the last three
days in bed with curtains closed eating
Papa John's so yeah I I am
I'm very glad that the the progress that
I've made and I do not miss that uh
texture of my own mind
my Iron Man Journey why is there so much
body positivity around plus-sized women
but so little for men
Chris bot come on let's see Step Into
the Fire crispart tell us why is there
so much body positivity I think that
there is a lack of body positivity for
men because they're great the
traditional gender roles and
expectations that have been placed on
them men are often expected to be strong
and muscular and any deviation from this
can be seen as a sign of weakness I
think it's important to recognize that
all body types are valid and to
celebrate the diversity of men's parties
Chris Bart come on
um
as a really good question I I've asked
this question a ton I did a video with
Zach a little while ago about how um
the comparison between women's lingerie
photos on a website and male underwear
photos and all of the guys were peeled
out of their mind and all of the women
were
bigger girls uh
the bare-faced answer is that body
positivity is a virtue signal that
proselytizes to the world about the fact
that you care about people of all sizes
especially women of all sizes but there
is no movement which is praising like
bigger men there are a lot of movements
that are praising bigger women therefore
all of the body positivity is aimed
toward the group that looks like it
needs help guys have had it good for so
long why should a guy that isn't in
shape
be uh given any sort of recompense it is
usually all done to the women another
part of this which I've spoken about a
ton and I really love this concept is
that male self-development sees the
person as mutable and the world is
immutable so it's the male's job to
change himself because the world's not
going to change for him female
self-development sees the person as
immutable and the world is mutable which
is you are already perfect as you are
the world needs to change around you and
I think that this is massively
patronizing to women like if I was a
woman and that was what the world was
telling me you don't need to worry let
us move all of these obstacles out of
your way with Marvel series and movies
or Disney or whatever I think [__] you
like I I'm a competent agentic person
that can do her own [__] I don't need
you to do this for me but given the fact
that body positivity is warping the
world around women of different sizes
and men for the most part are being told
like
better get in the gym buddy
Emily may sturt do you think people have
too high expectations of relationships
now
maybe but to a degree yeah actually
um and this is on both sides of the
fence I think that uh
it is very very easy to presume that
because you have access to such a huge
pool of Partners
there is always going to be something
more optimal for you right you're going
to look over the shoulder of whoever
you're with to just see what's coming
next next thing is what Logan URI called
it um
people want their soul mate that sexual
paramour they want their best friend
they want the future partner and raiser
of their children they want the pillar
of their community
but who who are we to say that you
shouldn't ask for that from a
relationship
um
I don't know I it obviously if you have
two high standards it means that you're
going to end up either alone or
permanently unsatisfied so individually
it's sub-optimal societally it's
sub-optimal because it means that fewer
and fewer people are getting together
it's very difficult like it I'm
struggling to find a way to say you
shouldn't do it because it sounds a lot
like me saying you should settle I'm
like well [__] hell like that doesn't
seem like very firm ground to me to
stand on but basically to a degree you
will have to compromise there is going
to be someone out there that is 90 or 95
right but if you don't like the fact
that they slurp their tea on a morning
or that they wear bell bottom or fled
jeans instead of tight jeans or
something like look is this really a
non-negotiable for you or are you just
nitpicking because you want to try and
find 100 because 100 may be out there
but it's basically going to be
impossible so two degree yeah maybe
dialing that back would be a good idea
uh J
son 1989 top five books for
self-development uh I am going to ask
Chris Bott what he thinks the top five
books for self-development are because
you can't Weedle his way out of this one
uh number one The Power of Now by
Eckhart Tolle not bad number two The
Seven Habits of Highly Effective People
by Stephen Covey never read it number
three How to Win Friends and Influence
People by Dale Carnegie never read it
Number Four The Four Agreements by Don
Miguel Ruiz read half of it number five
The Alchemist by Paulo coella got like
one and a half right Alchemist would
probably be in there
um
Atomic habits essentialism by Greg
McEwen let's say The Alchemist because
Chris Bott said it
um what else would I put in there the
April understood the universe by Steve
Stuart Williams
and
hmm
let's say the way of the superior man by
David data however there is a list of
100 books you can read before you die if
you go to Chris willex.com books go on
uh escaping mediocrity how do you judge
the potential of a guest interesting
person breath of breath of knowledge
breath of knowledge yes
um it's
whether or not I'm interested in them
whether or not I want to hear them
say things on a podcast the at the
moment what I'm realizing is someone's
ability to communicate is probably the
tightest bottleneck of all of the
different things you can have someone
that has amazing insights but if they're
really struggling to get them out of
their mouth it's basically unlistenable
and you can have someone that's got you
know
acceptable moderate lessons about life
and the world but a really really great
Candor and the way that they speak and
and the a compelling Storyteller they're
phenomenal so I think optimizing toward
good storytelling good communication is
great
um which is why
yeah just am I going to be interested in
this person is the best litmus test
because that's going to take into
account all of that stuff above
uh holy wool can I offer you a free
sports massage when you're in Sydney
James can vouch presumably James Smith
sure uh for the people that don't know
we've been advertising for dates for the
tour and a lot of listeners are in
Australia so it would seem that I'm
going to Australia and Sydney at some
point David vertlib advice for social
anxiety slash public speaking
um
I have only done a little bit of public
speaking so I'm not massively familiar
with that given the fact that I'm about
to do a live tour probably gonna have to
spend a good bit of time getting over
that for social anxiety no one cares
what you're doing
nobody cares about you at all uh
every single person is completely
wrapped up in debt on lives
when you walk into a room no one's
looking at you when you drop a glass of
Coke down the front of your top no one
cares no one remembers when you leave
within 20 seconds no one gives a [__]
like there is nothing more liberating
than realizing how indifferent the rest
of the world is to what you're doing you
are the center of your own universe and
you basically don't even exist in
anybody else's that should be the best
answer the best antidote to social
anxiety that I can think of
uh doctor direct it's a good name a lot
of you podcasters at top have the same
sponsors do you truly believe in their
products so I'm guessing that this would
be stuff like athletic greens and uh
better help and maybe I don't know what
else manscaped so every single sponsor
that I have on the show I use athletic
greens I use every single day element I
use every single day manscaped I don't
need to use every single day thankfully
but I use it on the days I need to use
it uh
I truly do you truly believe in their
product I do I can't speak for all of
the rest of the guys but
there are more people that want to
sponsor the show than slots I have on
the show therefore I'm in the luxurious
position of being able to choose who
comes on the show who I'm going to get
sponsored by
which means I can say no to anybody that
I don't believe in like I wear gymshark
stuff I train in it anybody that see me
training in Austin knows that I just
basically live in that stuff anyone
that's seen me traveling knows that I've
got element or athletic dreams with me
uh you know it's
I understand that the
there's probably a bit of skepticism
around the fact that why is it that all
of the big podcasts use the same
sponsors but the reason that they have
the biggest budgets are because they're
the ones that the most successful and
the reason they're the ones that the
most successful is usually because
they're the best so it's a little bit
circular but yes I do in short I do
AJ credia what do you think about
physical appearance and attraction it's
fundamental uh I I don't believe that
you can fake attraction it would be
that would be way too blue pill let's
see what Chris but says because if Chris
but says that maybe I am a blue pilled
[__]
um what do you think about physical
appearance and attraction don't say
something stupid I think physical
appearance is important but it's not the
only Factor when it comes to attraction
I think that there are qualities uh to
look for that go beyond physical
appearance such as kindness intelligence
and a shared sense of humor not going to
get hard off the back of in like a
shared sense of humor and I think
ultimately it finds it's important to
find someone who you can connect with on
a deeper level yeah uh physical
appearance and attraction are
fundamental that being said people can
be sexy in ways that aren't to do with
their physical appearance it can be the
way that they hold themselves can be
their sort of manner and girls that have
got a little bit of sass are you know
hot
but it's not to do with necessarily
their appearance
but it's a huge lever like the thing
that you are attracted to the way that
it shows up remembering that almost all
of your senses are dedicated to the
visual field
it's a big deal so
yeah massive uh curling TX what's the
scoop on marriage contracts prenups and
Dowry what's the future look like in
that Arena can laying out your plan for
the future and boundaries for your
person progeny and property make the XX
more secure and the X Y has defined
goals that's for the AMA I I thought
that prenups were relatively watertight
and since I've started so delving
further into the world of why guys
specifically are avoiding marriage and
in some of the threads that I've been
involved in people have said you know
I'm not going to get into a relationship
so that a woman can take half of my
thing and I well-meaningly said well
just why don't you get a prenup and then
it seems that these things kind of don't
really count for much and that the judge
can just throw them out
if they want to which kind of begs the
question like what's the point of them
um so I need to do a lot more reading on
this so I can't give you an answer but
I'm glad that you've asked the question
because it's something that I really
need to learn about
uh Benjamin cootie his real name is Chad
Williamson
those who know Stardust I don't know
Stardust and I don't get that reference
so if someone wants to explain it to me
please do
Dave novel population collapse is the
most interesting news subject for me
that I've learned about in the last 12
months what's the most interesting news
subject you've learned about over the
last 12 months you stole mine Dave
because for me it is what I'm captivated
by uh I was already on the mating crisis
stuff probably 18 months ago so I can't
say that from the last 12
let's say the um impact of hormonal
birth control on women's psychology or
maybe intersexual competition and the
difference between how male and female
coalitions and friendships work
Ed
I want to start a writing business I'm
decent at writing but I don't know how
to start any advice I don't know what
you're going to sell as writing is this
copywriting do you want to get paid to
be a writer on sub stack
first thing that you need to do is have
an audience you need to be able to reach
people that could maybe want to pay you
to write stuff so build up something if
you're going to be a writer it would be
best to do that off the back of a
platform that is heavily geared toward
writing so sub stack start a sub stack
write one blog post every week for the
next six months promote it get into that
content creation game and see where you
go from that you will naturally start to
accumulate people and if you don't if
you're not picking up people or if
you're finding the writing thing too
hard maybe writing isn't right for you
Joe one novik
best friend is aiming down how to deal
with close friends unwilling to move
forward Chris Bott
come on now
something good
it can be difficult to watch a close
friend struggle and feel like they're
stuck in a rut the best thing you can do
is be there for them and offer your
support let them know that you are there
for them and that you're willing to
listen and help in any way you can
encourage them to take small steps
toward their goals and celebrate their
successes no matter how small remind
them that they're capable of them
admiring their goals and that you
believe in them achieving their goals
and that you believe in them
not bad from Chris but there
I don't think that that's too far off
um
another side of it is it's not your job
to drown whilst trying to keep somebody
afloat who doesn't want to swim like
you can continue to encourage to cajole
to coerce someone to
improve themselves but
there are upper bounds and after a while
you realize that you're basically
exchanging your growth for their loss
and after a while it may be best to find
new friends
Bjorn Rasmussen Chris I was wondering
how many of you are listeners are female
and never thought of your podcast as
four men but recommended your podcast to
a female friend and she apparently
thought it was sexist which I don't
understand at all so I'm curious if it
is just her or if women don't tune in at
all very good question around about a
third of the listeners are female so I
maybe they're all sexists maybe every
woman that's listening to this right now
is a sexist uh but yeah it's between a
third and a quarter of the audience are
female
for me personally I have never tried to
make this podcast for any sex I am a guy
so my insights around male psychology
are always going to be deeper but
this year I would I would Hazard a guess
that we're probably not far off 50 50 on
male to female guests so many over the
last few months of all of the
intersexual Dynamic stuff you know
people from researchers from different
backgrounds phds
um you know [__] this is your brain
on birth control by Dr Sarah Hill no guy
really in their right mind should be
interested in that apart from the fact
that they're potentially getting into a
relationship or it's their mother or
their sister or their friend or whatever
my point being
I really try hard to just follow
whatever I'm interested in and whatever
side of that that falls on so be it
however
a lot of girls tune in and to those of
you that are here I praise you and your
estrogen uh for blessing us with your
time thank you very much uh Untold
encounters hey Chris congratulations on
the agent of the Thousand Subs you
definitely deserve it because of the
great content you create that has made
me think differently and better about
life decisions thank you very much
question I remember your conversation
with Mary Harrington where you said you
have not looked into surrogacy in some
of its ethical problems are you planning
on having a conversation with Katie
Faust since she has been talking and
researching the ethics and problems of
surrogacy and gamete donation and how
they could be potential children's
rights violations I am not familiar with
Katie Faust however
I have a list and she is getting added
to the list so thank you very much for
that uh s Don Chris being an OG listener
since lockdown 2020 and I'm genuinely so
stoked to see you grow I wanted to ask
with the increased success you still
seem to be the same person how have you
fought off the keeping up with the
Joneses mentality that is so prevalent
in the US and also in the UK such as
buying a Rolex a sports car and
designing clothes Etc
also do you see yourself living in the
in Austin slash the US long term or can
we see return back to the tune
um
a few things first off designer clothes
have never attracted me uh I dress
almost exclusively for comfort and
convenience
um and like fancier clothes basically
get less uncomfortable so that's been
easy I am actually kind of interested in
buying a nice watch just because I've
become a fan of the watches themselves
uh sports car
I don't know I
I got Ubers everywhere in Austin at the
moment
um
I have no real sense of self-worth that
gets taken from Material desires I have
none of it I don't judge myself based on
the boutons that I'm wearing or the
like the the jacket that I've got or the
the brand of car that I drive like I
like nice things but I like nice things
in as much as they functionally
facilitate what I want to do with my
life
um
you know in future maybe I'll get to the
stage where buying a Rolex or a sports
car or something isn't as so high of a
bar to get over that I'm going to be
bothered about it but let's have other
stuff that I would spend my money on I'd
invest in companies I would pay for
experiences for me and my friends I
would spend on growing this show and and
like I I took
good example
um
the Vegas trip that we did for David
Goggins towards the back end of last
year
flew me and all of the production team
out to Vegas a bunch of friends came in
from Dubai a bunch of uh staff came in
from the UK other friends came in from
America Michaela and her husband and a
bunch of other people and we went out on
a night out we went to Cirque du Soleil
we did a ton of stuff
that is the best way that I could spend
my money
compared with buying a Rolex or a sports
car and it cost less it cost less than
all of those things and yes don't still
have it now but I've still got the
memories I've got some of them it was a
bit it was a slightly heavy weekend Ben
Middleton keep up the great work
question would you ever have a guest on
who couldn't bring in couldn't bring
much to the table intellectually no
modern wisdom but potentially would
bring in huge views for your show
so I don't have a problem with someone
who doesn't bring much intellectually as
long as they're interesting like it's
not just intellectuals that are
interesting
um optimizing for people that are just
big names that I'm not interested in is
something that I really don't want to do
I think I've managed to stay clear of
doing it so far
um
I'm trying to even think like who
who would be the thing is that most of
the people that would bring in huge
views
would be interesting to me in one form
or another Because by the fact that
they've got such a gravitas around them
they're probably living an extraordinary
life in one form or another which I
could learn a lot from and then we could
dig into it and everyone would get to
find out about what their lives like so
um
I would have someone on who doesn't
bring much to the table intellectually
but I would almost never bring someone
on who I wouldn't I straight up wouldn't
bring somebody on who doesn't interest
me like what's the point like it's my
show it's my it sounds so much the only
child in me is coming out this is my
show my show and I have no one else no
one else gets to tell me what to do
um it is my show I've always followed my
instincts with it I've always brought
people on who I'm interested in which is
why you've been
subjected to endless numbers of human
nature and evolutionary psychology
because that's what I'm interested in
right now previously it was existential
risk before that it was CrossFit before
that it was life hacks after that it was
productivity tips
that's the way that I'm working so
intellectually
versus interest I think is the way that
I'm framing it
Peter capusi uh you mentioned that
you're doing 240 minutes of Zone cardio
awakens on two cardio a week I think
that's supposed to be is there a certain
reason you do this type of cardio what
is the benefit compared to other forms
of cardio training for you doing 180 and
this is Andrew huberman you know it's
just
human is speaking out of my mouth here
Peter Atia said the same thing basically
you want to get about three hours of
zone two which is probably 125 to 140
beats per minute uh of cardio in per
week it's good for heart health I wanted
to be more calm I wanted to have a lower
resting heart rate and a higher HIV
that's the best way to do it
Red Beard how should you deal with pride
after a glow up let's see
what crispot has to say about this you
big cook
it's important to recognize that a glow
up is a positive thing to be proud of
yourself for the hard work and effort
you put in to achieve it however it's
also important to remember that it's not
about physical appearance that there are
many other aspects of life that just
important celebrate your accomplishments
but also remember to stay humble and
kind to others bit bit mincy that wasn't
it
um how should you deal with pride after
a glow up
I don't know man I mean a lot of people
struggle with imposter syndrome which is
basically the opposite right it's that
you've had the glow up and you still see
yourself as the glowed down
the worst version of you so
um
maybe do the thing that homozy said
actually which is starting around with
people that are you know like uh get
into a room with bigger people so to
speak so
if you do have a glow up get some hotter
friends and then you're gonna feel
ugly again maybe that would work
Christopher S huge congratulations Chris
yours is honestly one of the most
intellectually honest and diverse
podcasts in the game thank you very much
in the war of art Stephen pressfield
writes that our job in this life is not
to shape ourselves into some kind of
Ideal we imagine we ought to be but to
find out who we already are and become
it you've spoken about the influence
this book had on you so my question in
regards to balancing practically with
the concept of going pro what advice
would you give to a writer for example
who hears as though they were put on the
planet to write that lacks the Financial
Security to commit wholesale to be so
creative a vocation
or more specifically how did you balance
the output that eventually springboarded
your growth with your previous
professional commitments appreciate you
appreciate you too Christopher good name
um it's hard man like there are um
literal material
[__] like physical constraints on how
many hours you have in a day and
creativity gets constrained down more by
that if you are working in a job whilst
trying to do the writing thing whilst
trying to deliver life I was trying to
bring up blah blah blah it's gonna be
tough
um
what advice would you give to a writer
that feels as though they were put on
the planet to write yet lacks the
Financial Security to commit wholesale
to so creative a vocation
you've just like dip your toe in one
step at a time if you are risk-averse I
am massively risk-averse I did the show
alongside running the business for
basically the first four years of it
um
and then finally after I'd proven to
myself that it was going to be able to
work I was able to take that step I
could let go of the thing that was my
sort of security I could move into the
thing that was going to be much more
risky
um I think that is
probably
the best place to start
um in terms of balancing the outputs
accept the fact that this is going to be
hard
this is why most people can't do the
thing that you're trying to do most
people can't become a writer because
they can't deal with the discomfort of
doing both
reliable work to keep the lights on and
creative work to build the writing
career at the same time some people may
have a rich father or win the lottery or
you know fortunately sell a business and
then they can pivot if that's not you
the price that you have to pay to get to
the life that you want is
eating [__]
and doing two things that are both kind
of difficult and sapping at the same
time and on the other side of that
hopefully you get something that's right
and and is a much better life for you
but even if you don't you've closed the
loop of wondering
wonder what would have happened if I
tried to commit for two years to become
a writer whilst I was working in that
factory or whatever
Danny Johnson if you were to appear on
diary for CEO what question would you
leave for the next guest did appear on
Diary of a CEO Danny I wonder if this
was posted before that one went live
um
the question I asked was one that I
stole from a friend a guy called George
Mack and
the question was
what topic currently overlooked by the
mainstream media in future will be
studied by historians
[__] good question there
Etsy bags would you ever start an only
fans Chris Bart come on
say yes say yes
say yes no piss I wouldn't start no new
fans I believe everyone should be able
to express themselves in whatever way
they choose but I'm not comfortable with
the idea of monetizing my content in
that way Chris but it's it's sex neutral
what are you talking about apparently
not sorry mate uh
best platform to learn skills like
marketing Etc not just getting educated
by uni I would say YouTube uh you know
homozy's books bloody hell read those
and read 100 million dollar offers 100
million dollar deals which is going to
be out soon there you go
javray no that's jabri again you're not
having two sorry javeray uh jargon
junkie can you do a session with Rhian
Stone you both talk about similar things
I saw a quote from Rhian that said
something like
um
after a life of privilege equality feels
like
uh persecution
he was basically saying that
um somebody that has had an unseen
undetected position of privilege for a
good amount of time
when they are asked to when the field is
asked to be evened it feels like they're
being pulled back and I thought that was
really interesting but I'm not super
familiar with anything else that they do
so I'd have to look into it
Peter sadness not a question but I'd
like to thank you Chris your podcast
really helped me in understanding myself
in the world we live in thanks to you my
health is much better than before as
well as my self-confidence thanks to
Apple episodes with Goggins or Joker
willink thanks Peter I appreciate you
thank you very much
Hamza L azawi what businesses slash
income sources do you have if you don't
mind sharing yeah sure so I've got the
show uh we've got that on audio on
YouTube
I have a number of properties in the UK
so I guess like real estate I have some
very basic [__] investing which is just
an s p tracker that I dollar cost
average into every single month filling
up my what in the UK we have a thing
called a uh interest fee free stocks and
shares Isa which allows you to basically
um lump a particular ton of money in per
year and you're allowed to do that tax
free and then the downstream benefits
from it are also tax free so I'm maxing
out that
um little psycho
like Amazon affiliate stuff which is
[__] pennies anyone that thinks that
they can make money off Amazon
Affiliates is moving far more traffic
than I am uh
that's it really I life gets paid for by
the show uh and
the sponsors that I work with YouTube ad
Center revenue is good it's okay it's I
would have loved to have been a part of
YouTube before the adpocalypse or
whatever it was called I can't imagine
how much money people were making that
but um I know I feel like I am leaving
probably quite a lot on the table in
terms of
monetizing and stuff I've never been
that good at building businesses I only
realized this recently being a
businessman self-identified businessman
for ages
I I I don't have that hunger brain to
like really really get after it and just
make tons of money which is good as
we've said today about the materialism
thing but it's also makes me think well
how much am I just leaving on the table
I could earn it and and do anything with
it so I know we'll see I I do want to
monetize a bit more about appropriately
after a while
um
Pete de Jean could you share again why
you prefer element and why you take it
daily awesome content keep it up thank
you prefer it uh prefer to what I'm not
sure I take it daily because it is
better for you on a morning than a
coffee your adrenal system the caffeine
that salt acts on is active for the
first 90 minutes of the day your
adenosine system isn't so having coffee
first thing in the morning is pointless
you're just ramping up your uh like
adenosine
um ramping up the amount of caffeine
that's in your body while it's not
binding to the adenosine receptors
and you might as well just take
something to tastes really really nice
and is refreshing and optimizes your
hydration and your appetite and your
brain health and does everything else
and then you can have your coffee or
your caffeine or whatever a few hours
later
um
dreams do you do you have do nothing day
or are you constantly working or
thinking about working let's see
what Chris but says are you
do you have do nothing day are you
constantly working I'm thinking about
working I try to take at least one day a
week to do nothing horse [__] Chris bot
absolute horseshit Chris Bart got it
wrong I tried to take one at least one
day a week to do nothing and just relax
I think it's important to take time to
recharge and give yourself a break from
work on these days I like to spend time
with friends and family read a book
Outdoors uh or just take a walk and
enjoy that
um only got two pieces of family Chris
bought both of them live in the UK
that's mum and dad so I don't get to do
that
um I do like to spend time with friends
and family I like to take little breaks
go and play Pickleball be in nature do
stuff like that but no I I'm usually
always thinking about something
um but I enjoy like that's revitalizing
to me is thinking about things but
pressing the gas pedal of how much to
work and how much not work is
um
important
uh
hounsy boy do you think there is a
connection between the masculinity
crisis and recreational weed come on
crispart let's get a good
question in here
I don't think there is a direct
connection between the masculinity
crisis and recreational weed however I
do think that recreational weed can be
used as a tool to help people relax
reduce stress which can be beneficial to
those struggling with masculinity issues
Chris bott's a stoner who knew
um I actually think that there is I
think that there's a good bit of
evidence that suggests that
um guys that are using screens that are
on a combination of pharmaceutical
prescription painkillers and or
recreational weed I think it is probably
causing them to just optimize for
comfort and convenience
um
I would love to see some stats around it
but my off the top of my Dome I'd say
yes okay I think that's enough for today
but before you go I want to say a big
thank you to Zachary and Miguel from
aiship.co they were the people who made
the Chris bot for me I don't know
whether you thought that was cool today
I think it's really funny to kind of ask
a language learning model version of me
the questions if you think I should keep
doing that on the next few q and A's
then just say so but that was great um
so Zachary Miguel from aiship.com if you
need an AI solution they can do all
sorts of things and you can check out
the site it's linked in the description
below aiship.com
that's it I'll see you at 900k
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]